that Friday feeling this time with an
added bonus the country's top earners
many in the city are about to be
thousands of pounds better off like
endritt cambaro who's cynical about the
top rate of income tax cut I understand
that they're trying to regenerate
investment and growth in the financial
sector and people who are perhaps by the
articulation bringing more jobs in into
the economy but uh will future
generations to come pay for it for
certain
will it help me for time being yes so
thank you very much government for now
around 660 000 of the highest earners in
England Wales and Northern Ireland will
benefit from the scrapping of the 45p
rate getting back on average 10 000
pounds a year all in the name of growth
there is evidence cutting High tax rates
attracts people in it happened in the
1980s when higher earners even those
with Celebrity Status like the rolling
rolling came back to the UK when the tax
rate was cut from 60 to 40 Pence but
what's not yet known is whether or not
it will make a tangible difference to
growth
analysts say if taxes are high it can
deter investment even if maybe you're
thinking today that the government
hasn't given you a great deal in terms
of those tax cuts then by boosting the
top earners potentially they'll invest
more if they invest more they create
more jobs maybe they pay more and that
could be good for everybody
the cap on Bankers bonuses has also been
lifted alongside the tax rate Cuts
leading to accusations of misplaced
priorities what we've seen today is an
inequality budget major tax cuts coming
down the line funded by borrowing
they're going to be across income tax
which is going to benefit the wealthiest
with the removal of the top level of tax
bold headline catching Cuts but concerns
over possibly widening the gap between
rich and poor May well take the Shine
off Adele Robinson Sky News the city of
London